josé antonio castet le vainqueur
surprise du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle chilienne avec 28% des
voix admirateur de donald trump et de
jaillir ball sonar ou et de leurs
méthodes polarisantes de campagne il est
l'expression d'une extrême droite
compenser démodé depuis la dictature
d'augusto pinochet c'est une droite très
pinochetiste d'ailleurs procédant aux
castes le candidat de l'extrême droite
chilienne et s'est affiché toute sa vie
comme une péniche et y il a dit lui-même
que pinochet s'il était vivant ou votre
aide pour lui
avec 26% premier tour en face un jeune
candidat de la gauche il ya briel boric
35 ans ex leader étudiant de la grande
révolte de 2011 qui porte les espoirs
des chiliens qui descendent dans la rue
depuis deux ans pour exiger des réformes
sociales retraite santé éducation pas
mal de chiliens sont inquiets d'hommes
bord et de l'autre il ya beaucoup de par
certains ici au chili et au québec les
chiliens du québec ont voté au premier
tour à 70 % pour le candidat de la
gauche de qui va dépendre le vote des
jeunes sur le chili a explosé à une
explosion sociale il ya deux ans avec un
gouvernement définira des droites sans
doute mais pas à l'extrême droite de
croissance on casse on peux juste
imaginer ce qui pourrait se passer avec
un gouvernement aussi décomplexée comme
celui d'être santana casse
après la révolte populaire de 2019 les
chiliens ont élu une assemblée
constituante qui doit rédiger une
nouvelle constitution qui devrait
effacer les aspects contestée de celles
héritées de l'ère pinochet le sort de
cette constitution qui doit être
approuvée par référendum probablement
l'an prochain dépend de l'élection de
dimanche parce que d'un côté on a gardé
le bolide qui est vraiment représente le
oui à la nouvelle constitution
représente tous ont cette envie de
changement
et de notre côté on a ressenti le cas ce
qui est finalement a été toujours sur le
camp du non de rejeter d'emblée tout
changement d'heure qui ait changé la
constitution ça ne change rien une
élection clé tout va dépendre l'avenir
d'un pays en proie à des doutes profonds
sur lui même jean-michel le prince
serait du canada à montréal
[Applaudissements]